Traductor: Máximo Hdez
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
En las primeras horas
del 13 de agosto de 1961
trabajadores de Alemania Oriental,
flanqueados por soldados y policías
comenzaron a rasgar las calles y
a erigir barreras en todo Berlín
y sus alrededores.
Esta noche marcó el comienzo de uno
de los hitos más infames de la historia,
el Muro de Berlín.
La construcción del muro
continuó en la siguiente década
mientras separaba familias,
cortaba barrios
y dividía no solo a Alemania,
sino al mundo.
Para entender cómo llegamos a este punto
tenemos que volver
a la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
EE. UU., Gran Bretaña y Francia
unieron fuerzas con la Unión Soviética
contra las Potencias del Eje.
Después de derrotar a la Alemania nazi
cada una de las naciones victoriosas
ocupó parte del país.
La división iba a ser temporal,
pero los antiguos aliados
tenían desacuerdos
sobre sus visiones
para la Europa de la posguerra.
Las potencias occidentales promovieron
economías de mercado liberales
mientras que la URSS trató de rodearse
de naciones comunistas obedientes
incluyendo una Alemania debilitada.
A medida que sus relaciones
se deterioraban
se formó la República Federal
de Alemania en el Oeste
y los soviéticos crearon la República
Democrática Alemana en el Este.
Los países satélites soviéticos
restringieron el comercio y el paso
por lo que se formó una frontera
prácticamente intransitable.
Se conoció como la Cortina de Hierro.
En la antigua capital alemana de Berlín,
las cosas eran en sí muy complicadas.
Aunque la ciudad estaba totalmente
dentro del territorio de la RDA
el acuerdo de posguerra otorgó
a los aliados la administración conjunta.
Así, EE. UU., Gran Bretaña y Francia
crearon un enclave demócrata
en los distritos occidentales de Berlín.
Aunque oficialmente se les prohibió
a los alemanes del este salir del país
en Berlín, era simplemente
una cuestión de caminar
o tomar un metro, tranvía o autobús
a la mitad occidental
para luego viajar
a Alemania Occidental o más allá.
Esta frontera abierta planteaba
un problema para los líderes de la RDA.
Habían apostado por representar
la resistencia comunista contra Hitler
y retrataron a la RFA como
una continuación del régimen nazi.
Mientras EE. UU. y sus aliados invirtieron
dinero en la reconstrucción de la RFA
la URSS extraía recursos del Este
como reparaciones de guerra
haciendo que su economía planificada
fuera aún menos competitiva.
La vida en la RDA estaba bajo el ojo
vigilante de la policía secreta, la Stasi,
que con sus informantes y espionaje
telefónico vigilaba a los ciudadanos
por cualquier indicio de deslealtad.
Si bien existía educación y asistencia
médica gratuita en el Este
el Oeste se jactaba de sueldos más altos,
más bienes de consumo
y una mayor libertad personal.
Para 1961, cerca de 3,5 millones,
casi el 20% de la población de la RDA
se había ido, entre ellos
muchos jóvenes profesionales.
Para evitar más pérdidas,
Alemania Oriental decidió cerrar
la frontera y así llegó el muro de Berlín.
Extendiéndose por 43 kilómetros por Berlín
y 112 a través de Alemania Oriental
la barrera inicial consistía
en mallas y alambre de púas.
Algunos berlineses escaparon
saltando sobre el alambre
o a través de las ventanas.
Pero cuando la pared se expandió,
esto se hizo más difícil.
Para 1965 se habían añadido 106 km.
de hormigón de 3,6 metros de altura
cubierto con una tubería lisa
para evitar escaladas.
En los siguientes años,
la barrera se reforzó con abrojos
perros guardianes
e incluso minas terrestres
junto con 302 miradores y 20 bunkers.
Una valla paralela delimitaba una zona
de 100 metros llamado la franja de muerte.
Allí, todos los edificios se demolieron
y el suelo se cubrió de arena
para dar una línea de visión
clara para los cientos de guardias
con la orden de disparar
a cualquiera que intentara cruzar.
Sin embargo, casi 5000 personas
lograron huir de Alemania Oriental
entre 1961 y 1989.
Algunos eran diplomáticos o atletas
que desertaron en el extranjero,
pero otros eran ciudadanos
comunes que cavaban túneles
nadaban a través de los canales,
volaban en globos
e incluso estrellado
un tanque robado contra el muro.
Sin embargo, el riesgo era grande.
Más de 138 personas murieron
al tratar de escapar, algunos por disparos
a plena vista de los alemanes
occidentales que no los podían ayudar.
El muro estabilizó la economía de la RDA
al retener a su fuerza de trabajo,
pero empañó su reputación
convirtiéndose en un símbolo global
de la represión comunista.
Como parte
de la reconciliación con el Este
el tratado fundamental de 1972 reconoció
de manera pragmática a Alemania Oriental
mientras que Alemania Occidental
conservó la esperanza de la reunificación.
Aunque el régimen oriental
permitió poco a poco visitas familiares
intentó desalentar
el ejercicio de estos derechos
con un proceso burocrático arduo
y con tarifas altas.
Sin embargo, estaba
abrumado por las solicitudes.
A finales de la década de 1980
la liberalización de otros regímenes
del bloque oriental
causó manifestaciones masivas
por libertad para viajar y democracia.
En la tarde del 9 de noviembre de 1989
la RDA trató de calmar la tensión
facilitando los permisos de viaje,
pero el anuncio trajo a miles
de berlineses orientales
a los puntos de cruce fronterizo del muro
obligando a los guardias sorprendidos
a abrir las puertas inmediatamente.
Las multitudes se regocijaron
en Berlín Occidental
mientras la gente
de ambos lados bailaba sobre la pared
y otros comenzaron a demolerla
con las herramientas que tenían a la mano.
Aunque los guardias fronterizos trataron
inicialmente de mantener el orden
pronto quedó claro que los años
de división habían terminado.
Después de cuatro décadas oficialmente
Alemania se reunificó en octubre de 1990
y la Unión Soviética cayó poco después.
Hoy en día, algunas partes del muro
siguen en pie como recordatorio
de que cualquier obstáculo
que impongamos para impedir la libertad
también lo podemos romper.